[Music]
i'm here again with my favorite
molecular mixologist i don't get to say
that often today we're making some fun
and unusual summer cocktails please
welcome from belvedere vodka claire
smith hi claire
all right it is summer uh people like
their summer uh alcohol i mean this is
the perfect time of year for you because
you like summer girly pink
frilly drinks so it's totally i will
admit i am a fan of a sugary drink i i
and i think it takes a real man who's
secure in his manhood
to uh admit
that
that worked
but i i don't mind a sugary uh sweet
drink what are we gonna make the great
thing about summer as well is you get to
work with some amazing tools uh so not
only are there like girly frilly drinks
but you get to work with things like
this what is that i don't know what that
is this is a pineapple corer
i'm going to get you to call this
pineapple while i'm busy making uh pina
maria which is a bloody mary with
pineapple juice and stuff but we're
going to put it in this awesome cored
out pineapple okay so to
[Applause]
push it in and then turn it all right
and then oh yeah well it's not going oh
turn it this way okay the other way wait
i'm turning it this it's turning it this
way what did i do wrong what did i do
i didn't even get that oh that way okay
a strong man who knows what he's doing
you know hold it for yeah yeah yeah get
in there get involved okay well stop
talking to me while i'm done
making me nervous
no no keep talking i liked it when you
were talking it was kind of sexy and
then what do i do you need to pull it
out now i had trouble earlier so i had
to put it between my legs
you have long legs you have good perches
but also strong muscles to pull it out
oh yeah and then
all right
so
now that we have a vehicle that's
actually very cool all right now we have
a vessel
for that lovely
this is how they did it on gilligan i
never realized that
so we're just gonna so in here i've got
some uh bloody mary we're gonna use this
awesome pineapple that you've called so
beautifully for us yes you only have a
little bit of pineapple juice on you so
far we're not making enough mess i don't
think not my suit yeah exactly
belongs to turner okay so we blend this
up this is gonna give you your like
pineapple
tropical tiki style drink okay so that's
pineapple and how much vodka's in there
you know as much as you feel like it's
summer you know kick back with a drink
[Applause]
in there as well
delicious and you know some for andy
some for everybody
yeah yum
we're gonna have such a party we're
gonna get our bikinis on conan where's
your bikini
all right moving on okay what's
happening now the drink so that is the
completed drink yeah okay that's the
completed drink just like that i like
two umbrellas okay all right totally
manly and
is it yum it's so delicious that is
amazing that is fantastic guys you gotta
you got to try this get involved this is
fantastic come on over here join me it
took you long enough
[Applause]
okay
oh my god that's great isn't that
amazing
where's that drink called again the pina
maria i don't remember thank you for
cheering for cleaning my glasses cone
that's very helpful
yeah the bloody mary that's the bloody
mary it's a bloody mary vodka by
belvedere
moving on thank you so much for that all
right so again using um what are we
doing now what are we making we're gonna
we're gonna do a well we're making a
cocktail we need corn
it's summer so you're gonna use some
summer ingredients i'm going to get you
to chow grill this corn and then we're
going to make a chargrilled corn
daiquiri charbrilled corn daiquiri all
right
grilling do you need to oh so you use
this to grill it yeah and this is
actually a nicer way of doing it because
on a grill you can lose control and you
get burnt but you know yeah you can't
get hurt using this flamethrower
so much safer you hold it while you burn
it
okay so i did that in the car yeah
[Music]
touch me again
[Music]
shake this up again showing your
masculine prowess when we shake over
here
remembering the shaky spacey shaky
what's this what's the shaky face well
you know the shape the face you make
yeah
says a lot about
okay so we're gonna strain this in here
oh my god this isn't that beautiful my
kids never see that
strain it into your hair do a
straightening yeah why straight i like
the corn giblets in there man
that's so weird in your teeth it's not a
good look so that's a corn toasted
cornbread lip balm
oh i found it i'm drinking okay
hey you're getting a little loose here
you're right there
[Applause]
all right all right we just have uh like
30 seconds left and you said this was a
fun idea for the for for people in the
summer so these things you want plastic
receptacles by the pool no glass so why
not drink from a bucket and spade
awesome why not drink from why not
because it looks really sad
also chilling down chilling down what's
this chilling down with some vodka what
is that do that what do you think this
is just chilled vodka and you can chill
down just spread it and then just like
walk in through it yeah like a mist go
for it
and again spray spray not on me not on
me not on me on you okay i don't know
why would you do this why would anybody
do this
you just totally made a fool of me for
no reason
[Applause]
i guess
[Applause]
if you've got kids in the house that's
insane that's daddy's squirt gun
[Applause]
yeah i knew this would get out of
control
i was trying to give you a drink all
right i'm sorry
it's always good to combine guys
just drinking responsibly yes drink
responsibly that's the belvedere message
this is very responsive
please i say
i mustn't lose sponsor hey
that was a lot of fun and we learned a
lot that's the important thing
claire smith always a delight